okay [ __ ] okay we're gonna be doing
we're going to be doing this weird
science it's been a long time so let's
see what's going on meet me there and
I'll explain everything okay what the
[ __ ]
okay okay let's see oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
oh ok kind of like that one up that's
okay
dude this motorcycle is shocking dope I
don't care what all yall people say okay
this is the best oh [ __ ] my [ __ ] that
can okay
there we go you know the [ __ ] Hourani
I guess him yes I I too am relieved
mm-hmm oh yes right away smiling
you
ok
it was a dark and stormy the [ __ ] a
heavy wet and I get by mother nature huh
Johnny we're about to jump Johnny they
failed you Johnny but I never will I'm
your number-one thing was this kind of
time what is that for money I've been
collecting [ __ ] house in for nightlife
all teed-up dumb he come
i got i had had enough things that he
touched by was wrong
the [ __ ] is this
Johnny
hold it you cloned gat yeah that's tense
all right so where's I'm getting to that
part
oh you guys [ __ ] huge
No
ok yeah
wait we are going to find our friend
chef sit the [ __ ] down Jimmy lead this
in a professional huh okay
you are in bed you biggie this is gonna
be [ __ ] Oh Aaron you have any idea
where to start Johnny's pissed he'll
want a gun try friendly fire everything
was that cat and that would be his first
time he's in a strange place and unarmed
hello is my first thought here yeah but
you knew we had to do a clone of gat
ain't gonna know that his brain
scrambled sounds like he wants to make
someone pay for ayesha's death she good
point would've thought maybe get would
have been that planet same yes not oh
sorry am I talking to wear to still get
whoopings close by
ok Oh anyway talk more cuz i got a piece
of steak stuck into idea what that i'm
trying to get out and I'm saying you
know 10
gown
oh [ __ ] you can hear him morningstar
feet that the Johnny too i plan on a
scam our heroes okay let's interrogate
one alive with the only avenue for a
value one alive we're gonna figure out
what's up what the hell do you want want
to keep yeah that's funny what the
morning star was doing here as long as
you don't give me to that perch he
tagged some of our guys nearby so we
were tracking him down oh can I go you
better find gatton for these guys do it
secretly alive ical there
the church wait what the [ __ ] is johnny
gat out he's that Mia technically legal
monitor Oh Vic right we got it police
were called to this bag hey what sounds
like Jenny okay yeah this is getting
very
thanks to the SS down stretch
it's how they's wrong a lot
faster on this is [ __ ] slow
tireless batch of I hand over the state
like advice of their intelligent
attractive friends we raced over to the
local strip joint ready to deal with a
ball 32 investigation holy [ __ ] this
place is [ __ ] up ok I guess I'm after
block angle isn't huh where's all the
police and where's Johnny damn would you
just tense mess
hurry allow that stretch I already
called the police look it will you
Saints did to my club hold up man we'd
have nothing to do with it what happened
here where did he go Jesus that big guy
came in screaming his name and something
about stripper poles and then started
trashing the place people panic that you
ran off it got nice I shut that ass wait
for Jimmy okay
you want Jimmy we're under attack here I
know I heard on the police scanner dad
you trapped inside I have a way to track
guy right there wit dope [ __ ] no waiting
there for the kid not chess and Joey why
the chase began their standard technical
legal
hey from the police mark garing a lie
open fire hordes of enemies bearing down
on them the danger was it's me take it
so far tamari do we do her never once
they lose faith in their friend and a
kid income oh [ __ ] they called in the
SWAT team I can
a lot of my important i would say
stripper blood strengthen side at the
darkest hour alike here are the day
arrived unafraid and bracket what the
[ __ ] you couldn't attach something
better than this car very liable that
explains so much I can't drink that I'm
like a bike here just give us a fright
and arrived just in time to see the case
from
in here Tasha amazed by the device he'll
protect a perfect hey support
explanation on how it works
chef
ok ok
ha various areas hold the shitty strong
okay where is it written up chef
oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] helicopter inside
above us I don't say
okay oh [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] is that have had to look
at I never tried it
a lot of [ __ ] going on here that's all I
gotta say
ok
oh sure
[ __ ] that was our guys know these guys
seem to be more
oh [ __ ]
yeah that's a lot of [ __ ] action
not yet hey this is like the craziest
mission while I waited so long for this
oh my god
oh my goodness
I think
Oh
in 200
how though what
take it out for gaining on our target is
it
[ __ ] a so we're just giving up backup
plan correct me okay hmm i'm pretty much
it like you're watching this thank you
dicks out for Harambee